PROFESSOR: Welcome to the
applet Amplitude and Phase:
Second Order II.
This applet is a sibling of
the applet Amplitude and Phase:
First Order, which I used
to introduce the MIT Mathlet
collection.
Its color coding,
placement conventions,
and its functionalities
are identical to that one.
This applet represents
a mechanical system
driven by the motion of
the far end of the dashpot.
Let's begin by animating the
system to see how this works.
You can see the
dashpot is moving
up and down sinusoidally,
driving a mass in yellow.
And the mass is also
constrained by a spring
at the top, attached to
a fixed wall at the top.
Perhaps we should
animate this again,
so you can see the
whole thing at work.
This applet, and its siblings,
show only the steady state
or periodic solutions
to these equations.
They don't allow you to
pick initial conditions.
They don't represent the
effect of transients.
In the applet, x represents
the position of the mass,
and you can see it
read off on this scale.
It's represented in yellow
on the graphing window here.
And we declare x to be
zero when the spring is
exerting no force on the mass.
It's at rest.
We declare x to be
the output signal
of the system in the mathlet.
y denotes the position
of the plunger,
and it's read off
by this scale here.
We declare y to be the
input signal of the system.
Now the force
exerted by a dashpot
is proportional to
the relative velocity
of the cylinder and the
piston sliding inside of it.
The proportionality
constant is called b.
As a consequence,
the right-hand side
of the equation controlling
the position of the mass
is b y dot, b times the
time derivative of y.
This is a good example in
which the right-hand side
of a linear equation
in standard form
is not just the input signal.
In this case, it's not even a
multiple of the input signal.
It's a multiple of the
derivative of the input signal.
The most important
case to study is
that in which the input
signal is sinusoidal,
and that's what is
represented here.
In the applet, we take the
amplitude of the input signal
to be one.
If the amplitude of the
input signal is doubled,
so is its derivative,
and so by superposition
the amplitude of the output
signal would also be doubled.
So setting the input's
amplitude equal to one
isn't really a restriction.
In this situation, when
the input amplitude is one,
the output amplitude is the
same as the gain of the system.
We can see how this
output amplitude depends
upon the input frequency
by opening the Bode Plot
window here.
This opens two windows.
The top one represents
the amplitude
of the system response, the
gain, as a function of omega.
And we can start
with omega small.
When omega equals zero, the
plunger isn't moving at all,
and the mass has no
reason to move either.
So x equals zero, the spring
is relaxed, there's no motion.
When omega increases, the
system response becomes greater.
But you'll notice
something interesting.
In this system,
when omega is small,
the system response
leads the input signal.
That is to say, the
phase lag is negative.
And that's represented here.
This is a little confusing.
This is a graph of the negative
of the phase lag or the phase
gain.
And that's a positive angle, in
this system, for omega small.
You can see the effect.
The mass seems to be
pulling the plunger,
although that's not
actually what's happening.
When omega increases,
the amplitude
of the system response increases
until a critical moment
when omega takes on
some critical value.
This is the resonant
frequency of the system.
And at this point,
the system response
is identical to
the input signal.
Shall we see what this looks
like by animating the system?
Now the plunger seems to
be locked to the piston.
That's not actually the case,
but the system is simply
operating in harmony here.
It's the resonant frequency.
When omega increases
still further,
then the system
response falls off.
The phase lag becomes
positive, the response
falls behind the input signal.
And that's all visible from
the Bode plot pictures.
As I look at this, I notice
something interesting.
When the system response
reaches a maximum or a minimum,
that's exactly the same moment
as when the system response
curve crosses the
input signal curve.
So in other words, the
amplitude of the output signal
equals the value
of the input signal
at the moment when they cross.
Let's see if that is
always the case when
I change the frequency here.
That always seems
to be the case.
Very interesting.
And in fact, perhaps we should
change the values of b and k
to see whether that
continues to be the case.
Yes it just seems to
drag up and down there.
And similarly, if I change the
value of the spring constant k,
again that peak seems to move up
and down along the blue curve.
Very odd.
We'll come back to that.
Here are some
further observations
that you can see from
experimenting with this applet.
First of all, let's
watch what happens
if I change the value of
the damping constant b.
I'm going to watch the Bode plot
over here, the amplitude Bode
plot.
Well, it changes, but one
thing that doesn't change
is the position of the
resonant peak there.
In other words, the
resonant frequency
seems to be independent
of the value of b,
of the damping constant.
The second thing you can
observe, as I vary b,
is when b is large, the
resonant hump is quite broad,
but as b becomes smaller,
that spike becomes narrower
and narrower and narrower.
And the third thing you can
notice from looking at this
is as b gets to
be small, the flip
between phase lag of close
to minus pi over 2 to a phase
lag of close to plus pi over 2
happens more and more abruptly
as I change the frequency
from something small
and cross through
that resonant peak.
Now the system response is
ahead of the input signal.
But it very quickly
flips to being
behind it as you cross
the resonant frequency.
And that transition happens
more and more rapidly
as b gets to be small.
Each one of these
three observations
can be verified by calculation.
The relationship between
the gain and the phase lag
can be illustrated very well
using the Nyquist plot, which
I'll open using this key.
This is a plot of
the complex plane,
and on it is drawn a
complex number in yellow.
And that complex number has
a magnitude and an angle.
The magnitude is the gain.
This yellow strut is the same
length as this radius vector.
And the angle is the
negative of the phase lag.
It's the phase gain.
So when the angle's positive
here, it goes through zero here
and becomes negative
down here, when
the phase lag becomes positive.
So you can see why it is
that the resonant peak occurs
at exactly the same instant
as when the phase lag is zero.
That says that this
trajectory, this Nyquist plot,
goes through this point,
which is the point
1 in the complex plane,
where the angle is zero
and the magnitude is 1.
This trajectory is in fact
independent of either, both,
of the system parameters.
If I change them,
many things change,
but the shape of this
trajectory, the Nyquist plot,
is independent of those
two system parameters.
And in fact, it's a circle
of radius 1/2 and center 1/2.
You can verify that by
calculation as well.
That fact explains
the observation
we made earlier, that the
amplitude of the system
response, the gain, seems to be
equal to the value of the input
signal when that
maximum is achieved.
In other words, the claim
is that the gain equals
the cosine of the phase lag.
The gain is the cosine
of the phase lag.
This curve is given by the
equation the radius equals
the cosine of the angle.
r equals cosine theta
is a polar equation
for this particular circle.
And so the fact that this is a
circle is the same as the fact
that we observed earlier, that
the solution curve crosses
the input curve just when it
reaches a maximum or a minimum.
Well, in addition to the spring
system shown in this applet,
this very same equation
models the response
of an AM radio receiver.
The input signal is the
incoming radio signal,
which contains
electromagnetic waves
of many different frequencies.
The output signal
feeds to the amplifier.
You tune the radio to a
particular angular frequency
by adjusting k, the spring
constant, which in the circle
model is the capacitance, so
that the resonant frequency is
the desired frequency
that you want to tune to.
Then the output generated
by the other frequencies
is much less than the output
generated by frequency omega_R.
How much less depends on how
sharp the resonance spike is.
The sharper the spike,
the better the tuning.
You can make the spike
sharper by decreasing
the value of b, which in the AM
radio model, is the resistance.